first of all you got to give yourself
permission to really
have what you want okay gotta have the
thing that you're visualizing be
something that is authentically
something that you want number two you
must see yourself taking the steps the
tiny actions of doing the work that will
lead you to creating or having what you
want third you got to feel in your body
what it feels like to do the work and
you also have to feel pride as you see
yourself doing the work because that
amplifies your mind body and spirit
really
imprinting and training and preparing
for it and fourth
obviously you gotta take the actions and
all of that manifesting and preparing
inspires you to take the actions
but one place where so many folks get
stuck when they start trying to make
manifesting a daily habit
is you go and you know what you want
but then you sit down and you try to
imagine
what the steps are that you need to take
to get there and you don't have a clue
your mind goes blank if this is you i'm
so excited that you're watching this
because the simple trick based in
science is called the power of
objectivity all you got to do is stop
visualizing yourself and insert your
friend mel robbins or insert somebody
else that you love and admire and the
power of objectivity is going to
immediately switch you from a blocked
mind to one that is bolder and more
creative and able to visualize the steps
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how you can manifest things into
existence
enjoy
there's extraordinary research that was
just written about in the harvard
business school review they did eight
different studies at the university of
wisconsin where they were studying the
power of objectivity and with thousands
of participants here's what they found
when participants tried to visualize
themselves
doing hard things
immediately the participants when they
thought about themselves doing something
hard like let's just say asking for a
raise okay i want you to imagine
yourself asking for a raise or applying
for that dream job when you visualize
yourself doing it you immediately focus
in on minutia you start imagining all
kinds of things that could go wrong you
start arguing against yourself and doubt
comes flooding in you have a very
cautious mindset when you place yourself
in those scenarios
however
if you were to visualize me mel robbins
asking for that raise
immediately your mindset switches to
being very bold being creative seeing
all kinds of opportunities and in fact
when you not only visualize me your
friend mel robbins asking for that raise
that you want when you give me advice
you're super enthusiastic you're like
mel you should go for it and i bet in
your life
you have probably
told friends or loved ones you should
ask for more money and you mean it
because you're visualizing them but you
yourself
won't visualize yourself doing that you
talk yourself out of it we've all had
this experience you yourself are
probably sitting there going right now i
constantly tell my friends you deserve
more you should break up with that jerk
you should go for it
but when it comes to yourself
you see the excuses of death so i want
you to leverage not only this common
sense but this research to your
advantage when it comes to manifesting
pick what you want and then if your mind
goes blank when it comes to seeing
yourself do the work literally just
insert your friend mel robbins or insert
anybody that you love rule number two
change your old personality with joe
dispenza how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being if you take
a thought and a feeling a thought and a
feeling a thought a feeling a thought
and a feeling that's called an attitude
a series of good thoughts with a series
of good feelings you say i have a good
attitude today
you have a series of negative thoughts
that are connected to a series of
negative feelings you see have a bad
attitude today so attitudes are just
shortened states of being good attitude
in the morning bad at two in the
afternoon
if you take an attitude and attitude
imagine you keep those up
and you string attitudes together you
create what's called a belief
and belief is just an extended state of
being so if you keep thinking the same
thought you keep hardwiring it in the
brain you keep feeling the same feeling
you keep conditioning in your body the
redundancy of that cycle over and over
again conditions the body to
subconsciously become the mind of that
belief and all beliefs
are subconscious states of being
okay
take a belief a belief a belief and you
string them together you form what's
called a perception and perceptions are
just such extended states of being
that we're unconscious and so then we we
edit out reality in fact
most people don't see things the way
they are they see things the way they
are
right and people are always filling in
reality unconsciously based on their
memory they could be married to a person
for 40 years and they don't see the
person they see the memory of the person
right and there's research to prove this
okay
so how do we change a belief or
perception about ourselves for our lives
okay we've studied this
okay let's just say that lack is
ingrained in there you got the story you
lived on the streets you lost everything
you got betrayed your business partner
took everything took your wife took
you got the story in the half okay
okay you got to start telling a new
story of the future right you got to
believe in that future more than you
have to believe in the past so how do
you do that
you only believe in the past when you
feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
the future right okay
so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about ourself and our lives
we have to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
condition in your body
and your body literally has to respond
to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion
you feel when you make that choice the
more you'll remember the decision
okay so then how do we
down regulate that old belief
if the trauma created an emotional
quotient of six
or seven then your decision to change
your beliefs gotta be a nine right and
you gotta come out of your resting state
and that moment has to define you you
could say i know exactly where i was the
time of day it was who i was with
when i made my mind up to change right
because you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotion right but the amplitude
of that emotion is greater than the
betrayal
boom the body starts responding to the
mind and
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally
so you brand you're impossible no your
body's actually getting the taste of
that future event experiencing the
future now exactly big explosion in the
quantum field big explosion so the side
effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion
you're basically remembering your future
and it looks no different than
remembering your past think
neurologically within the circuits of
that memory and feel within the emotions
of that new belief
and watch your life begin to change
because nothing changes in our life that
we change in when we change our energy
we change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lacking or lack of separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for us
to become abundant
we have to overcome the old personality
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business i'll see you
there rule number three focus on serving
with lewis howes if you are in a tough
financial spot maybe you're struggling
financially you've been trying to start
a business or a side hustle
i've been there i know what this feels
like it's not fun for a long time i was
living on my sister's couch and i didn't
have much money it was really stressful
i remember this feeling of being stuck
feeling like i was never going to make
any money and when i was focusing on
that feeling of i'm never going to make
this money i feel stuck i feel trapped
when's this gonna happen
feeling this anxiousness this stress
around it
it was really impossible for me to think
of creative ideas it was impossible for
me to
take action because i was living in the
stress as opposed to the gratitude for
what i was having in that moment i
should have been focusing on you know
what my sister is allowing me to stay
here for free so i have some time to
learn a new skill
i made a hundred dollars this day i
should be grateful for that not focusing
on what i'm lacking or what i don't have
but what i am creating on a daily basis
and i started to ask different questions
around this time like how can i be of
service to other people how can i add as
much value to someone else or what are
my top skill sets that i can use
to my advantage that no one else has
like what do i have i started writing a
list of all these different skills that
i had even when i didn't think i had
many skills i still wrote down a list of
the qualities i have of the skills from
the past that maybe i could apply to
right now and when i began asking those
types of questions i started attracting
the people who needed my skill sets and
services and i finally started to make
more money than ever before because i
was thinking about serving others i was
thinking from a positive grateful
standpoint about helping others and
starting a side hustle which turned into
a business instead of thinking
negatively about not having any money or
i'm sleeping on my sister's couch and
why is it taking me so long to create
this and i'll never make anything from
this situation i started focusing on how
can i add value as much value as
possible to this one person in front of
me right now how can i serve them how
can i create for them how can i connect
someone to them that could help them
what can i do to add value and help
someone else achieve their goals because
i think as zig ziglar said if you want
to accomplish all of your goals help
other people accomplish their goals and
that's what i started focusing on not
what i'm lacking but how can i give and
how can i add value to other people when
you focus outward on service you start
to really attract some incredible things
in your life it's unbelievable the
ripple effect the domino effect
one person helping another person how it
comes back around to you and if you've
ever felt this for yourself leave a
comment below of this feeling you've had
when you started adding more and more
value getting out of the negative
situation inside your mind and in your
body and focusing outward on helping
others it's incredible the things you
can start to attract and manifest in
your life rule number four practice
visualization with brendon burchard the
most important thing i know this sounds
so so silly but common sense is not
always common practice and that's why so
many potentially great people fail to
ever achieve their potential and that's
this
listen
you have to get your visualization game
down
visualization that means
listen when i wake up when i got a dream
i wake up in the morning before i get
out of bed i close my eyes i just see it
happening a little bit and i'll lay in
bed and let my mind and my body stir up
a little bit of excitement or sometimes
even anxiety about seeing the actual
thing that i want happen
that was for me at one part of my life
seeing myself on stages speaking and
training to people one part of my life
it was seeing my book come out and
seeing it on the new york times
bestseller list or seeing it on the
amazon bestseller list it was sometimes
seeing myself coaching major celebrities
or sitting side by side with an oprah
winfrey or tony robbins or larry king
all of which i've been able to do it was
because i
visualized what i really wanted but
here's the thing it's not just
visualization that's like
the first part it's also affect
we talk about high performance and in
psychology about this thing called
affect which is basically feelings and
emotions i i want you to allow yourself
to literally not just kind of casually
see it like put yourself there and feel
it and sense it and see and feel it and
drink it in like really take in the
ambiance the circumstance you like
really visualize and feel
what you are seeing
that's so key i mean as silly as this is
i literally would lay there and i'm like
okay if i'm going to feel like
feel like fill out the ideal
thing what questions would i ask to
really get going i just start literally
seeing myself at my desk in the morning
feeling filling out the high performance
planner
thinking about other people worldwide
filling out at the same time as me
and knowing that got this tribe of
people on this path of trying to be
their best with me and imagining people
coming up and says oh my gosh you know
brandon you completely changed my
morning you completely changed my weekly
routine you completely changed my life
because i never tracked my habits before
i never assessed my balance every single
week between
family friends work finances adventure
learning etc everything every tool that
we put in here i could just imagine
someone come up saying brandon i really
appreciate that part and i literally
just thought about it because i wanted
it to feel like you know i was excited
for the project otherwise what look how
easy it is to diminish anything in our
lives well it's just a book it's just a
planner it's just a it's just a video
it's just a cosmetic line it's just a
beauty thing it's just that like we all
diminish our dreams we make excuses and
we make our dreams like ah we throw it
away because we're scared to feel it you
know what i'm saying
it's easier to throw it away that's no
big deal avoid it not no problem
and we mess up
i want you to feel it stop detaching
from your dreams
stop avoiding that anxious scary feeling
of thinking how hard it's going to be
and thinking how great it's going to be
because most people just they don't even
think about it because it causes too
much nerves i'm like dancing those
nerves a little bit let them come up for
you because that's fuel man
that's fuel it's like less brown
toddlers you gotta be hungry you'll
never be hungry if you don't visualize
it see it feel it and want it i'm rule
number five the last one before some
very special bonus clips is use the
power of imagination with les brown the
biggest challenge i had to overcome and
it's a continuous challenge
is
allowing myself
to see myself
beyond my circumstances and mental
conditioning to live out of my
imagination rather than my history when
you are raised in a culture that
that constantly
you
marginalize you
and stifle your potential to move
forward i remember reading a quote by a
guy named richard wright who said
the impulse to dream has been slowly
beaten out of me through the experiences
of life
so just imagine in 1963
when i graduated from high school now
that's you know that that's a long time
ago
my my grandson said grandpa how old are
you i said 75. he said you are oh
19 seconds in 1963
here's what the statistics were in 1963
that
if you're an african-american you're the
last higher in the first fire if you're
an african-american
that a a white college
trained black person has less of a
chance of getting a job than a white
high school dropout that's in 1963.
according to the federal reserve that
still exists
so
so just imagine when an african american
graduates from college
and in debt
that a white high school dropout today
will earn more money three times more
money
than that black college graduate three
times more alright
why because of his paint job i'll never
forget
lewis i saw an interview with
larry king and this white supremacist
was being interviewed
and he said
tell me wh why do you why do you hate
black people he said because they're
black
so
and he said and he said and i'm white
so larry said
what did you have to do with that
and this white supremacist said what he
said
what did you have to do with your being
born
white and he didn't have an answer he
just got quiet
and and larry in that
question that strategic question
it created an aha moment hopefully for
that young man
i saw this video yesterday this lady
said i've got grandchildren i hate y'all
and i'm teaching my grandchildren to
hate you too wow
yes and i'll never forget when i was on
a bus coming back from miami beach
with my mother and they had signs on
miami beach that said
jews dogs and cullets not allowed
and and so
i asked my mother i said mama why do
they hate us so much and she said leslie
i don't know but don't you ever be like
them don't you ever be like them god is
love
and he who dwelleth in love dwelleth in
god and god in them you love people
regardless how they treat you
at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself worried or frustrated because
no matter how much effort you put in to
work and no matter how hard you work
your financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable well
what i can share with you
is you're not alone that's number one
and in most cases the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what
more of the same results but they are
looking for different results and so
today i'm going to show you how to break
that pattern break that cycle
now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and
it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits
then my result will change and what i
love to focus on having done an enormous
amount of brain research over the last
10 years is something called your inner
game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and i go well for what
she says well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth and she
said to me that she was a caregiver and
that she loved helping families who
needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year and so she really
didn't have enough money to be able to
take the care of her grandkids that she
wanted to to be able to take her
children on a vacation and so i shared
with her why do you think that you're
only earning twelve thousand dollars a
year and she said i don't know and when
i shared with her that she possibly
believed that that's what she was worth
and she said to me i think i'm worth
more i said well you might be able to
declare that you're worth more but if at
a deeper level
of your brain you have this feeling that
maybe you're not smart enough or not
good enough or not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was i helped her recognize
that beliefs drive behavior
beliefs drive emotions habits drive
behavior and in order to change your
results living paycheck to paycheck
being stressed out worrying about your
future or even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what i
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widow's
from a widow's pension and living
paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year just around two years ago i had
this idea i wanted to share wisdom at a
pace we wanted entertainment i wanted to
share wisdom in a way that it could
connect resonate and deeply evolve the
lives of people all over the world for
10 years before that i've been working
with individuals groups coaching at
universities companies and all of these
opportunities but i really wanted to
serve and connect with everyone across
the world i wanted to make wisdom
accessible to anyone who had one of
these i have one of those
so i was excited i had the energy the
enthusiasm and i was pitching my idea to
every single company that was online now
remember this is before i ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
i was who's this guy i applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea i waited a day
i waited two days i waited a week i was
rejected by every single one of those
companies before interview none of them
invited me for a phone interview none of
them invited me for a video interview
none of them even connected with me in
any personal way that's rude
i said to myself it doesn't matter let's
see what else i can do to try and make
my goal a reality
so i tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance i got
one answer and one answer only they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a master's and then
we'll take you seriously literally i was
getting rejected from every single
person i spoke to but inside of me i had
this desire i had this calling i had
this mission i had this vision that i
wanted to share everything that i'd
learned with people out there i
genuinely tried every single possible
method i could to break into the media
industry to the point that the only
thing that was left that i could try was
to start a social media channel and of
course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is that it reminds me
of a really powerful thought from thomas
edison he once said when you believe
you've exhausted all options remember
this you haven't that thought stayed in
my mind the whole time what i learned
from all of this rejection from all of
this failure from all of these clear
no's was one really important thing and
today i want to give that as a gift to
you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when i started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when i
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen that's when things started to
happen
this is nice
it's when i decided to take the
responsibility for sharing what i was
passionate about with the world and not
waiting for someone external to validate
me or give me permission or allow me to
do that
that's what made the difference if
you're feeling you've been going through
a lot of rejections ask yourself this is
your deeper passion and calling making
you want to move further number two have
you truly knocked on every single door
and number three are you working hard on
investing in your expertise and passion
so that you really have something
impactful to offer we live in a world
that reinforces a scarcity mentality and
that mentality keeps us in an energy of
lack it keeps us from attracting the
career path that we want the abundance
that we want and allowing us to really
live our purpose there are six common
blocks to abundance and we all
experience them in different ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith the fourth block is the
need to win in the place of having fun
because when we're so focused on winning
we lose track of what it feels like to
enjoy the process and that winning can
really get in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself now
that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to flow to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality the more positively the
universe responds to us this puts you
into an abundance mentality quickly
because the more you give the more you
will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous you're no
longer separating yourself from others
redirect your focus from what can i get
to how do i feel and really allow that
feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire your personality literally
yet is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
inspire new thoughts and that's called
evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you pay
attention to the cause outside of you so
the brain takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true i just want
to understand the maybe the larger the
event in terms of its emotion to you the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life
and it catches all of the brain's
attention so now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event
and you keep that refractory period of
chemicals going on for extended periods
of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional
reaction for weeks say for days or weeks
is called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry while this
thing happened to me eight months ago
i'm having one long emotional reaction
i'm memorizing my emotions you keep it
going on for years on end that's called
a personality trait so then a person
then is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right wow
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away to that person right because
they're capturing your attention so then
there's an energetic connection to every
person everything everything in your
past present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electromagnetic
magnetic field around the person's body
that's energy to heal that's energy to
create a new future with right and then
if you didn't want to lower the volume
to the emotion then just take your
attention off the person and every time
you take your attention off the person
if you became conscious of that you
wouldn't feel the emotion now the body
though
has been addicted to that emotion right
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion
and the body's going wait a second
you've been you've been doing this for
the last 20 years and all of a sudden
you're just going to stop hating and the
body says well i've been conditioned
this way and conditioning is based on
the past so when the body feels the the
lack of that emotion just like a drug
addict it says hey you're off schedule
here so now the body starts influencing
the mind to think about experiences that
are embossed in the brain that are based
on that emotion so the emotion now is
causing you to think in the past if we
teach a person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you going to do sooner
or later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude as an example yes the
person says well i can't feel gratitude
and i say absolutely you can because you
don't practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or your heart of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature of gratitude means the event
has already happened where it's
happening to you so the moment you open
your heart and you feel gratitude well
that emotion then is telling the body
that the experience has already occurred
and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny you've got to maintain
that modified state of mind and body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready because something weird or
unusual some synchronicity some
coincidence some opportunity is going to
land in your lap and you didn't have to
go and get it yes it came to you now
you're the vortex of creation so if you
say to me well i was feeling gratitude
but then there was traffic or my
co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life let me
explain what happened so this really
interesting concept called ghosts in the
nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out
and they come home and they've been busy
and you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and mom or dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on may 17
1972
but your nervous system remembers what
it's like
so fast forward you're now 51 years old
and
you walk in the house and there's a mess
everywhere and even though you have said
i'm not going to bulldoze and yell at
anybody
my body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw
and so what i'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
i was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for sure the mic for share the mic
now i'm trying to create a video and i'm
like doing take after take because i
want to get it right
and my daughter comes waltzing into the
room and was like
how long are you going to be doing this
and i was like
can't you say that i'm working i
literally like screamed at her and she
looked at me louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how's your
daughter
20.
and i said i calmly said you're right i
do
when i get interrupted
i
lose control of the response and i'm
working so
hard and the way that you and i'm not
clearly not mastering this yet
but the way that you do it is as you
feel it rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath
you can notice the pattern and you've
got to create a pause between the
emotion rising up and the reaction that
gets automated and for many people the
reaction loses to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you you hate being
interrupted by anything this is a great
introduction i did like i didn't do i
didn't do the bulldozer i was i was calm
because i wasn't a human being i'm only
mean to human beings
um i know like i a lot of people run
away they avoid conflict they say it's
just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict
continues to create a pattern where you
feel invisible and your boundaries are
trumped on that's a pattern
and you know here's the other thing
about patterns
running away
and being quiet might have saved you
when you were little
because if you were quiet and out of the
room you didn't get hit you didn't get
yelled at you were out of harm's way
so when you were little it was a genius
pattern because it protected you but the
issue for adults is that again we walk
around
with the patterns that we created when
we were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are
completely a robot to these patterns
several years ago
i went to see a friend of mine
and he is considered by all means one of
the leading experts in the world on eeg
and brainwave frequencies and really
understanding
how our brain waves affect
how we feel and what we think about and
i went to this biocybernaut institute to
be able to recognize one thing
number one was that my thoughts happened
randomly as a result of all of the years
of learning experiencing listening to my
parents my teachers my brother my sister
and myself and as a result of that i
developed these neural patterns or brain
patterns that created these automatic
thoughts
some of them are positive some of them
were negative however what i learned at
the biocybernaut institute was that i
could control
my thoughts
now listen to me for just a moment if
you think about this
are you your brain
well the answer is no your brain is an
organ however your brain has billions of
cells and those cells connect and talk
to each other
every time you have a positive thought
you reinforce that thought pattern every
time you have a negative thought you
reinforce that thought pattern even
faster now the reason that your brain
does this is because it wants to protect
you from any real or imagined danger and
so a negative thought
is something that happens in the brain
that when it happens it reinforces
itself way faster than the positive
thought so one of the things that you
can do
is this
number one
is give your brain a command since
you're not your brain you can do this
and science has proven this you can give
your brain a command
to let you become aware
of when you're having a negative thought
or even a negative emotion
so the first spot or the first part that
you need to take control over is the
awareness part of what's happening
within you
then the next part is to recognize and
realize that you don't have to play into
a negative thought you don't have to let
it control you you can actually observe
your negative thought you can observe
even a negative emotion or an unpleasant
emotion and you can surrender to it and
what does that mean surrender doesn't
mean give up
surrender just means allow it to happen
without getting emotionally attached to
it
now if you become aware of an emotional
or mental thought that you have that's
negative and you surrender to it and
just allow it to flow by
you can use the word next
in order to give your brain a command to
move on to the next thought or to move
on to the next emotion and so as you're
aware of it as you surrender to it and
use the word next what i want you to do
next is refocus
your brain on what you want
the thought to be and the emotion to be
so you can choose a polar opposite
thought
that will really empower you
to have the right emotion and more
importantly will empower you to take
action around the new thought and
emotion so again the three steps are
become aware of your thoughts and your
emotions
surrender to them by allowing them to
happen let them go by releasing them by
saying the word next and then refocus
your thoughts on what you want to
achieve what you want to take action on
and that way you'll start to be in
control of your thoughts your emotions
which will then drive the behaviors that
you want in order to achieve the goals
that are most important to you the voice
within us that believes that we are not
allowed to be happy
our card today is speaking to that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good
this is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to feel a sense
of serenity in our life
that is all quite backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am i to feel good
who am i to feel great who am i to be
happy
that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with kovid when we witness
people suffering we think well how dare
i be happy i would say to you how dare
you not be happy it's your happiness
it's the collective happiness it's the
group collective happiness that raises
the energetic frequency of the world if
we those of us who have moments of
happiness and grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion has momentum it has
power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your divine duty here on
earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good i want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you who are you not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but i wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or i didn't do that right i
want you to speak back to that voice i
want you to say thank you for sharing
but i choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but i don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but i'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for the
beautiful thing about monk life is half
the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you
how many wounds are you going to come
home with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded
i come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are
warriors in one sense
and so without wearing that so for me a
morning routine is putting on emotional
armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut
you're protected and i know that when my
morning routine is at its best i feel
protected
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened i feel weak
and so for me the morning routine as i
get strategic about it there's two
principles you have to know location has
energy
and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now
holds that energy
and this is huge like it's just so big
and i'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when i meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
south india it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like i lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in new
york
four years ago
and i just had a tiny corner which i
dedicated to my sacred practices so if
you you don't have to have a big home to
do this you don't have to be wealthy to
do this you can find just a corner in
your home that you dedicate your
meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing
time has memory
and this is something that people
underestimate
when you do something at the same time
every day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got a
regulated diet you'll feel hungry you'll
feel tired at the same time every day
you will look towards that coke can or
that sugar or that chocolate bar at the
same time every day and so when you're
meditating at the same time if you're
exercising at the same time so what i
recommend to people wow is your morning
routine needs four aspects and it's
simple and i call it time it's about
making time in the day okay so time
stands for t-i-m-e
t stands for thankfulness there needs to
be
even if it's five minutes five minutes
of thankfulness of gratitude every
single morning and that has to be
gratitude that's specific it can't be
gratitude that's generic so generic
gratitude is something that anyone could
be grateful for oh i'm grateful for the
sky i'm grateful for air i'm grateful
for water that's cool but it's generic
gratitude
specific gratitude
is i'm grateful for the fact that i have
someone calling me this morning i'm
grateful for the fact that i can still
call my parents i'm grateful for the
fact that i have this person in my
business who is having such an impact
i'm grateful you know it's specificity
yeah so thankfulness second one is
insight i think this is one thing that a
lot of people are missing which i
recommend people listening to you it's
like podcasts books and and make it
easier for yourself if you get this book
leave it open on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table i
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and i
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you just flick to a chapter randomly and
you pick up one line it will impact you
and it'll speak to you so insight you
need insight every day m is meditation
and i believe meditation is different
for different people as monks we did
walking meditations we did beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice i'd give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than i can i exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise
when i was small mom i was also really
undersized so it's probably one reason i
lift weights i was always every baseball
picture on the kid holding the sign in
the front right so i was small and
skinny they used to tease me eddie
spaghetti you know and i'd get bullied
at school and i never retaliated so i
had that mixed with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and i got to tell you that the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an outlet i finally
found something that i was pretty good
at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the fast kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business they said you know you're
intense when someone points out a gift
about you that you also kind of
intuitively know to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i want i am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now i believed i
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's [ __ ] but it's something you
know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time and so there's a
confidence no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it i am pretty
good at this this is a good program and
so the way we change your identity the
way i changed mine was by getting in
touch with what some of my natural gifts
were and then using them in my career
using them in my life that shifted the
weight right off of me because the
weight was i suck i'm shy i'm small i
have a screwed up family that's the
weight right the lifting off of the
weight is these are some gifts god gave
me or the universe gave me or that at
least i know i have and i can spend my
life using these gifts now i've got hope
now my identity is changing now my life
takes a different direction i think
we've been hypnotized and conditioned
into becoming materialists
i think
that we define reality with our senses
and i think that is one of the biggest
delusions so the fundamental question is
can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet but you've thought about
enough times in your mind
that your brain is literally changed to
look like the event has already occurred
now the latest research in plasticity
says that's absolutely possible and can
you select a new possibility in the
quantum field and begin to emotionally
embrace that future every single day to
such a degree that your body
as the unconscious mind
the objective mind does not know the
difference between the experience in
your life that's creating the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone to the degree that you
begin to signal new genes and new ways
to change your body
to look like the experience has already
happened now yes the latest research in
epigenetics says it's absolutely
possible now think about this every day
installing the circuitry every day
conditioning the body into the emotion
of the future
that your body begins to change to look
like it's already happened now this is
where it gets fun
because now you no longer have to go
anywhere to get it
now it begins to come to you you become
the vortex or the magnet to your destiny
so then people who come out of their
meditation and they say well i just
focused on my wealth why isn't it there
well you're not that good if you're
asking why isn't it there you're back to
the old person again
stay in that state for an extended
period of time
as
an experiment as the scientist in your
life to keep your energy connected to
the to the dream of your future
and then
see what kind of effects begin to take
place without moving into impatience
without moving into frustration
without starting to analyze why it
hasn't happened or when that is the trap
of defining reality with your senses so
you have the thought of your future and
you don't see it then you experience
separation
but people who are practicing this work
they have the thought of their future
and they feel the emotion of their
future they're still connected to it
right so that takes practice and it's
just learning like hitting a golf ball
hitting a tennis ball dancing with salsa
you know crocheting whatever it is you
gotta you gotta start out staying real
conscious and learning then you get good
at it and it gets to be instrumental it
gets to be fun and that's that's what i
want for everybody that the act of
creation
should be of blissful life ecstatic
loose
free process and um
and so
i love the idea of people taking time
out of their lives
to prove to themselves that if they're
defined by the vision of the future
then they're not living by the memories
of the past and that's where the unknown
exists so many people
the unknown is a scary place
so they don't see that future
because they're used to seeing that
future with evidence with their senses
and you have to be able to get beyond
that and stay in the unknown stay in
that discomfort and then in that moment
to be begin to self-regulate like oh i'm
starting to feel a little anxiety ooh
i'm starting to feel a little
frustration
that's the defining moment where your
body's going back to the past because
emotions are a record of the past or you
go into routine again so you catch
yourself
it's a victory
and if you keep catching yourself those
victories add up
and it's not so much
about your wealth or your health or your
freedom or your new relationship it's
actually about who you become becoming a
monk was my biggest dream growing up
from that time period that i made the
monk 18 which we spoke about the last
time i was here and so that became like
my identity from 18 to 22 and then 22 to
25 when i lived as a monk so it's like
that's been my identity for seven years
at least in my heart in my head
and so when you get to the end of a
self-awareness journey which is actually
the beginning but you get to the end of
it because you're like oh i'm not a monk
anymore and i'm sure you've gone through
similar things like oh i'm not a ceo
anymore of this right of a business that
does this or someone else may go through
i'm not married anymore
i'm now divorced
i am now not single anymore or i'm not
uh alone i've got kids right it's like
we all go through these identity
transitions in our life
and to me
going from being a monk to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that i'd
been through at that time
and the question that i'm having is
i'm having reflections on who i truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and i'm saying i want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and i love movies
and that's what the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who i am and what i love about
myself
and then i'm going but this doesn't
align with what monk life is meant to be
in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like i'm not comfortable
with that so when i share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
he's his advice and i think this is the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to university
and then they become professors
and there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs
or go out and work and he says which do
you think are better
i'm like
i mean neither really like i can't
really choose what makes someone better
and he was just like
that's the point you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but neither
is better and it was the simplest advice
it's one of those pieces of advice that
it's all about the person that says it
and not necessarily what you're hearing
but for me it just clarified the
judgment i had
the
attachment i had
that i could only be happy and
purposeful in this way
and that's really what we're all
struggling with that currently we all
have a projector screen up here that
goes this is what life's meant to look
like for it to be happy and then down
here we have the reality version of what
life actually looks like and we go oh no
they don't match that doesn't match
that's not working that means i'm going
in the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think
but you just don't want to go down that
path because it doesn't look like the
one you imagine and that's where i was
at
i was having to go down a path that i
didn't imagine looked like success
but then the question is well what does
success look like then and it definitely
doesn't look like the version in your
head
so to me i started to realize and i
genuinely believe this
and your affirmation is very useful to
me the three years of my life
living as a monk were like being at monk
school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that i've tried and tested in the last
seven years i learned it among school
but i tested it in in reality and i'm
only sharing what in the last seven
years it's perfectly worked for me to
feel like i'm exactly where i need to be
that doesn't mean i don't have off days
that doesn't mean that i'm happy all the
time it doesn't mean that i don't get
angry it doesn't mean that i don't get
upset but i'm going in the direction
that i want to be going in what is fear
is fear something that you should fear
no
i want you to imagine as you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
a light pops up
um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air
air pressure maybe uh you're missing air
or water in your windshield wiper maybe
the back trunk door is open
isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why
well when you understand how did this
organism
okay develop and how
does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external world triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a potential
that threat predator or threat at the
door
it lights up the fear signal sends
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the predator will go
away so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal
that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what what about a fear of losing
money and not having enough to pay the
rent the mortgage or for retirement what
if there's a fear of trying something
and then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my god if you
judge me then you're gonna reinforce my
low self-esteem of myself and then all i
should then who am i
you understand what's happening in the
circuits i'm just describing
so when our brain has
this fierce circuit activated do you
think the fear circuit causes you to go
oh hey let's take action anyway
or do you think it goes hi alert hi
alert hi alert be aware what's going on
what if you fail what if you succeed
what succeed and fail whenever that
circuit is triggered motivational
circuit shuts down whenever that circuit
is activated your thinking circuit shuts
down all the blood flow goes into a part
of your brain to help you do what
possibly run away protect yourself
it's a protection mechanism but here is
what i want you to remember
this automatic trigger and circuit has
been evolving for millions of years but
your specific experiences since you were
born in the modeling experiential
and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs
about things some empower you some
disempower let me give you an example
okay let me give you an example
when i say the word
or let me give you a different
same example with just a little
different story
if i say to you that i'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python how many of
you go oh wow that would be great
versus how many of you are going oh my
god let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run
versus oh my god that would be great can
you take a picture of me with it so i
put on social media
so
is it really the snake
that is the threat
or is it
your concept
in your brain the meaning that you have
associated with a snake that is
activating for some of you the reward
center
and for others the fear center same
stake stain stimuli there isn't even a
snake here i just add you think about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some reward circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged uh fear of disappointing
ourselves fear of failing if you're
succeeding there's 50 different types of
fears
we automatically trigger
the circuit
that does what stops our action taking
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with the feeling of love and
abundance and and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay
so the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right
that happens once again through books
like the universe has your back so
fantastic that you're doing that
transform fear to faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways from the
experiences that we've had as children
particularly young childhood experiences
but the good news is thanks to
neuroplasticity
our brain actually can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality we our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so one thing that you can
do simply in this moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself
you can
be in the proactive development of new
thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there's my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again
all right i forgive myself just showed
up again because that forgiveness will
dissolve that guilt and tension and fear
that you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought so
your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking what you
believe about yourself is the only thing
that matters at the end of the day no
matter how much outside affirmations you
get or other people telling you that
you're amazing if you don't believe in
your heart that you are amazing
it won't none of that will last like you
ever gone to an event or you ever made a
video or created something or you're
hanging out with a friend and they tell
you how amazing you are and that feels
good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades
but that stuff doesn't last you don't
have somebody being a cheerleader for
you every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting
your value as a human being
from other people when they tell you
that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believing
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
[Laughter]
i think for me it's this is why i
believe that lack of belief is
the world's number one problem
you know i can go and meet somebody and
feel them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home
back to a life that they
they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines and systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough
how do you think it's great to be your
own worst critic
i think it's great i think honestly i
think for a lot of people
we're not hard enough on ourselves let
me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things
we're very hard on ourselves but because
there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like i'm sitting here in a parking lot
these you know those i guess it's kind
of blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we can post all these great things
on instagram or wherever and make it
look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck hate their
own lives they are barely hanging on so
how do we get through it well yes we can
be harder on ourselves
but we need to balance that with more
self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great
what you're proud of what you're
grateful for
and it has to be consistent
otherwise you'll never get to where you
want to go and when you
love yourself more
that actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself more you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because
it's not going to push you over the edge
because you're not tying your self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of i'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when i go to events
a youtube event for example if i'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or youtube related
i'm going in thinking
i'm kick ass
and
because i feel that i don't need to say
that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's
masking and insecurity
right it's like those people who uh
we've seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even jay-z like early jay-z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like he doesn't care
you know he's walking on a t-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so
self-confident now that it doesn't
matter now it's actually expression
instead of masculine insecurity
most of us are just masking insecurities
instead of actually being self-confident
and so when i'm going to an event if i'm
talking about youtube i'm walking in
feeling amazing
and i don't need to
i don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and
it's actually the opposite i can go up
and say hey where do i suck
it's my favorite question ask why do i
suck where do i suck can you point it
out if i can find one person to tell me
where i suck at something how my videos
suck my thumbnails suck
do i don't believe that they suck
right
i think they're amazing
but because i think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how i think
it could be better
and so i think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that i do is i put music on
and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if they came on you would have to you
would have to move
right it doesn't mean that you're up and
like dancing through the whole house
going crazy in your underwear first
thing in the morning but something that
even if it's just making your head bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head bob
and you'd probably be singing maybe not
out loud but singing under your breath
i'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're
singing out lyrics
that are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on every day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from
feeling low and tired and just
what day is it what am i doing i wake up
every day like what day is it what am i
doing today yeah it's
but i demand excellence and that that
starts with music because i don't have i
don't want to spend a lot of time trying
to get into the right state of mind i
can command it whenever i want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to
the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing i'll do is i'll take
the dogs out and then i'll go for
what i call a believe walk and it's
probably the most important part of my
morning routine is i go for a believe
walk
and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and
i'll go for a walk by myself
with 20 pounds on my back i'll go
wrecking
a walk to
tim hortons usually get a coffee
you know this cost two bucks to
something
so
i only had
you know what's the what's the best
money i spend every year well it's the
700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and i'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and i'm thinking about what i
want to accomplish today and the lives
that i want to serve and the people i
want to help and and what i'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time
other people's emergencies of what they
think you should do with your schedule
today right that's what's in your phone
all the dms and the emails and the texts
and the missed calls and all it's all
other people's agenda for your time that
that is not an intentional life we wake
up like an accident and start falling
into what other people want us to do
today that's not what you need to do and
you need to protect your time
so the morning
having a believe walk for me if you want
to go on your own
whether it's 20 minutes or an hour
that's really just a feel thing too i
don't book anything until 10 30 at the
earliest in my calendar
most of my meetings would be 11 first
meeting would be 11 movement makers and
brand lytics i'll start at 10 30
and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
i want to do and so if i want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes i can do that because i'm
thinking because i'm brainstorming
because i'm i'm
going through an idea i treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate that
means it's the same thing i just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much i like something a little more
active so i go for my belief locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to
think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel
about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation and somebody else's
words of affirmation for us to
feel worthy
and flip it to say i am worthy
i am amazing
i can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible motivation from the one
and only wayne dyer check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there and i'll give you some
examples of them
and you decide whether they're to your
liking or whether they work or not
the first of these principles
came from a uh